aber
es ist einer der bewegendsten momente
der deutschen geschichte
donnerstagmorgen im deutschen bundestag
die gedenkfeier zum 77 jahrestag der
befreiung des kz auschwitz
der präsident des knesset des
israelischen parlaments micky levy nimmt
in seiner rede ein gebetsbuch zur hand
das ihm die holocaust gedenkstätte jad
vaschem in jerusalem zur verfügung
gestellt hat zum abschluss seiner rede
liste das toten gebiet aus dem buch vor
abdullah
dem 70-jährigen bricht die stimme weg er
ließ das gebet stockend unter tränen zu
ende berger ist man cool wie
michelle
obama barcelona
welt
israel
[Applaus]
viwis deutsche kollegin astrid zu ihm
ans pult liegt ihm tröstend und dankbar
die hand auf die schulter der
ergreifende moment endet in langen
applaus
[Applaus]
[Musik]